yo um talk about your your friendship
with Buster rymes Buster rymes obviously
is uh one of the greatest of all
time yo shout out to Buster he he bought
me my first diamond chain that's sick
yeah he B he he bought me two Diamond
chains nobody know that I lost the first
chain yeah when Buster RS bought me that
diamond chain he replaced it
yeah you replaced it so you told him
like spent the bag yo I got a crazy
story to tell you what happened so bust
RS buys me a diamond chain right okay I
lose it performing with him in 50 Cent
on stage okay at least at least you
didn't lose it in I didn't lose it from
no reason I was on the stage I was Buck
Wilding FX by the way sick Flex yeah
sick Flex yeah I was like Buster I lost
the chain he was like what H how you I
said I was on stage it just fell off
yeah he was like that's not my fault
because like if I'm on stage performing
that's the jeweler's for or whatever but
we [__] with the je we [__] with the
Jeweler so what happened was he bought
me another chain and nobody knew and I
just acted like I never lost the chain
same chain same chain same chain right
spent that bag wow but then it's going
[__] your head up the dude came like
listen so mind you I lost the chain and
he bought me a new chain right then
Buster rolls was performing at a show
and some guy just came to him and was
like listen I found the chain like I
know this means a lot to scar and you
and I know how important this chain is
so I want to give it to you so now you
got two so now I got two chains yeah wow
shout out to Two Chains check you out
shout out to Buster Ry crazy crazy story
yeah were you are you nervous performing
like on stage with Buster rymes and 50
Cent yeah man I'd be [__] my pants
it was too much people bro and I was
just looking at everybody I'm just like
man I got to kill it I can't [__] they
show up yeah cuz bust is like one of the
greatest performers of all time if not
the he's like top three for sure yeah he
might be number one I love Buster arms
the way him and uh and spliff be on
stage and they do the thing where like
he turns them down and he starts rapping
all quiet and then he turns up yo spliff
mad funny bro no it's crazy best hype
man of all time yeah no it's crazy
everybody who never if you like ever
want to watch a live hip-hop show and
like take some notes go watch Buster
Rhymes perform um so what's going on I
know you got the new record that just
dropped uh the the Blick record
obviously no statements going crazy is a
album on the way what's what's happening
with the
project yo Blick is out right
now but we got a remix coming top of the
Year who's on the remix I can't tell you
that the way you just looked over there
was like should I say cuz I was like
even confused if I was able to say that
like what's this Snoop I'm cool was
saying that huh who we got a we got a
remix droper top of the Year what's your
favorite rapper Who's my favorite rapper
I'm curious if you know M I don't know
who's your favorite favorite rapper but
just know he's your favorite rapper
Who's on the record I can't tell you
I'mma tell you after the interview I'm
going what city are they from I can't
say that cuz then you're going to know I
won't know unless they're unless they're
from Charlotte and it's the baby the
dirtiest part of the
trenches what state can't tell you y I'm
not going to let them figure it out from
[Music]
Chicago Chicago shout out to Chief ke
though it's not Chief
Keef could it be is he from Chicago yeah
all right good could it be little Dirk
no but I [__] with Lil Dirk man shout
out to Lil Dirk I hope we we get a song
soon dirtiest part of the trenches
Southern trenches Northern trenches the
dirtiest part oh nasty nasty just the
Chester Pennsylvania
can't have you ever been to Chester
Pennsylvania it's it's not good but look
so we got Blick coming the remix the
remix what a visual with a visual then
we got a EP coming okay can we talk
about it yeah what's up when's the EP
coming the ep's
coming next year I mean obviously it's
December the EP is coming next year okay
and the EP is called scars and Stripes
oh I like that
lots of
features stuck
with you just can't tell me okay I can't
tell you shout out to my godom I didn't
wear a bracelet today every time I wear
my God mom's bracelet it means I'm going
to be protected she's with me that's
dope I uh my dad has a godmother I don't
have one I don't know do you have like
is your godmother still with us she
she's alive oh she's alive good for her
[__] I got to ask I don't know are you
like have a good relationship with her I
love my godom so much she's like my
second mom you know uh in uh like uh
where I'm from in Arizona it's a lot of
uh you know obviously my son's half
Mexican and uh I noticed that a lot
of uh my wife's and my baby Mama's
Family they'll pick someone as The
Godfather or the godmom and then they
end up beefing with them weird and then
it's like they're just like Gone With
the Wind it's like oh yeah that's your
godfather but [__] him you know can I
say something I feel like God moms don't
really get appreciate it a lot you feel
me cuz it's like they're literally for
you when your mom is not there like my
mom you would hope so of course yeah
yeah well my godom yeah she's like there
like as a mom and she just hold a lot of
like baggages for me you feel me like so
she stepped in and held it down she
stepped in yeah that's dope that's good
shout out to God Mom man um who would
you okay how about this right now
there's I I my my two favorite movements
going on in new New York are you and the
uh 41 the 41 kids uh I love those guys
man and and shout out to Jen she's she's
killing it um have you guys worked
together or you guys I feel like it'd be
dope if you guys did some [__] together
I I love they they they so lit and
they're so positive they're just having
fun they ain't on no [__] like yeah
they just Good Vibes you know what I
mean and like we if we work that's going
to be
amazing yeah if we work if we work we
was in the booth and [__] we we played
some [__] that's good yeah who's uh
who's your like
uh bucket Le bucket list feature that
hasn't happened yet cuz you've already
worked with Snoop and I mean you I mean
that that's a big deal oh that's the
realest [__] Snoop Dog the realest the
realest [__] like you don't even know
that [__] put me look he jumped on my
song yo Snoop Dog is the realest [__]
mhm he jumped on my song he brought me
out to you did you go to did you go to
his compound in uh Englewood look yeah
he jumped on my song No I know he
brought me out to the Yankee stadium for
free no charge
and he did it with no hesitation [__]
be funny with that [__] what you mean he
brought you like to perform with him at
Yankee Stadium yeah he brought me out to
perform I love Snoop Dog bro dead ass
that's my [__] in real life and he's
also the same we don't got to talk every
day just for me to right [__] with a
[__] you know what I mean like he was
just a fan like how did he even find out
I I'm a fan but he just loves my song
this is New York actually what happened
was I dm'd him yo listen this the LA
this is LA all I do is DM people I just
be dming these [__] the people that I
don't think I would ever even be able to
work with right I'll be like you know
what let me just try you got to take a
shot
everybody you would not imagine listen
bro the people you would not imagine I
got songs with is the ones I got songs
with because you dm' them just because I
dm'd them I think most artists have like
too much ego to like want to reach out
it's like bro just shoot your shot like
bro I'm talking about [__] you watch
you be like I would never be able to get
that that's fire so that's how it
happened with Snoop was a DM yep just
sliding in a DM listen artist if you
hungry enough you want to make it your
biggest resource is your DMs I know you
didn't uh you don't smoke weed but um
you didn't smoke with Snoop oh no I
didn't smoke with Snoop yet there's a
few guys like I smoke with Snoop I don't
smoke but for Snoop Dog I roll I feel
like snoop's one of the few guys who
like if they pass you the joint you're
like I mean [__] it it's Snoop I know
his [__] GNA have me Zed up